good morning and
welcome back to my channel so as you
guys can see i'm not in the van
um i am actually in basalt
colorado i am cat sitting in this
beautiful beautiful home um for this
lovely woman named beth
she owns this place which is actually an
airbnb
it's called the hills basalt and i just
love it it's
full of light there's trees everywhere
and yeah it's just very tastefully
decorated it's gorgeous
so the last time that i talked to you
guys i was in
wyoming jackson wyoming and i was there
for about
three weeks and then i moved on to
northern utah which was
beautiful during the autumn but the plan
was to stay in moab for a little while
just kind of
hang out in the desert where the
temperatures are relatively warm
and then head over to denver colorado
moab was so
busy like i've never ever seen moab that
busy before there were
so many cars coming into moab when i
left i
only stayed for like 12 hours and then i
was like i'm leaving i ended up heading
straight to colorado
based out of a small mountain town where
there was an anytime fitness nearby
which bonus you guys anytime fitness
showers
in colorado and utah are open which was
a really nice change because
that was not the case in washington like
all summer fall by the way in colorado
is beautiful the weather was absolutely
perfect had a place to shower place to
sleep in the national forest
right by the river it was great so i am
camped
in colorado right now just outside of
aspen and
you can feel winter coming like
it's so autumnal right now but the snow
is definitely coming
anyway here's my view
and then all of a sudden the weather
said that it was supposed to snow
like a massive snowstorm couldn't
believe my luck there was a house set
here i don't know if i've mentioned this
before but i'm also a professional house
sitter it's one of the things that i do
to kind of break up my time on the road
so i applied
and got the gig it's absolutely
beautiful this house
and it's with a really really sweet cat
named lou
it's really nice to slow down
and have steady wi-fi and a shower
and a toilet and all of those things so
um
yeah i'm super excited for the sit also
because the owner used to live in
washington
and she loves to hike in camp and she's
like a total badass outdoor explorer it
ties nicely into
this episode where i'm gonna share with
you guys a backpacking trip i did with
two of my really good friends
chelsea and renee we did a backcountry
camping trip in the mount baker
wilderness up in washington
and it was so much fun i had a good time
filming they did a lot of filming
it was just like a fun collaborative
effort and i don't get to see
those two together very often because
chelsea lives in hawaii
so i'm really excited to share this one
with you thanks for being here
and i hope you guys like this one
[Music]
[Applause]
it's
is
[Music]
if i like hold on right there and i'm
like laying down is that strange
okay nailed it
basically just looks like i'm wearing a
hiking skirt i'm wearing a hiking
strawberry
[Music]
[Applause]
yep
[Music]
show me
what you eating christian i'm having mac
and cheese tonight organic
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i take my two toothbrushing verses
in the black country dental hygiene is
really important
kids 30 seconds on each side
just woke up there's chelsea the
caterpillar
still in her back
let's see how it looks outside
it's morning good morning you're stolen
my sleeping bag it's so
chilled hawaii girl is so chill
okay
[Music]
not wearing any pants it's really hard
you just like carry me outside
what are we having for breakfast well
we're making coffee right now
i had instant coffee and what kind are
you having
um it's really fancy power over i'm kind
of jealous
you guys look matching like little elves
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh there's so many up there here you go
renee pay you for your filming
yes
[Music]
there she um
[Applause]
[Music]
you